I'm passionate about positive thinking
from the early books written the the
power of positive thinking and all the
experts in the past many of them I I
knew them later on in life met them in
different parts of the world but I I
apply it because if you study any of the
writings and the teachings of positive
thinking you have to have a goal in your
mind otherwise you're thinking blindly
we don't walk in and you don't walk to a
destination without having an idea of
what you're going where you're going so
it's positive thinking isn't just
thinking to yourself well I can do
anything I want and so forth because
some things we can't do I I have some
people I know personally I wish they
felt they could float if they walked out
of an airplane in the sky no I'm not
being nasty I'm just being crazy but the
real positive thinking is having goals
because a golfer never hits a ball until
he sees where it's going never hits a
ball until he sees words otherwise it's
going neither does a pitcher when he
throws a ball so we have to have in our
lives some direction and we have to
think with with a positiveness that
we're going to take advantage of all the
opportunities that lead to that
direction but the interesting thing is
when failures take place and study the
lives of famous people they found
alternate routes which often caused them
to invent new machinery new
paraphernalia that didn't work when the
other thing failed because they had to
be resourceful the same as you are
in a war when you're playing a game in
which you're playing against a team and
something goes wrong it's a saint life
is really a game so you have to you have
to have a flexibility and those things
take place not only in knowing in your
heart and soul you're gonna find a route
you're gonna find the route to this
place you want to go to whether it's
working in a large food complex because
you like to cook and what have you and
your savor food or whether it's working
on a sports team or what have you but
you also have to figure
you know if this thing doesn't happen
maybe there's something in the
background there that I didn't notice
that I could take advantage of in the
same way that sometimes and let's take a
lesson from chef's if they don't have a
certain piece a certain appetizer that's
that's there for that food there's often
a couple of other ones that can be added
that turns out can make it a new taste a
new dessert and that's the way you have
to think about life as a meal that
you're adding